today is president Trump's 71st birthday
[Applause]
yeah Trump received a card from Vladimir
Putin that said I hope you're enjoying
the birthday present I gave you in
November
Oh strew today is the his president
Trump's birthday true story yeah Melania
surprised him by still living in the
White House
[Applause]
[Music]
I didn't leave you yet but very soon
we're all screwed on today President
Trump said the GOP health care bill that
passed through the house was mean and
difficult to defend yeah
then Trump said another in other words I
love it
big changes big changes for Fox News Fox
News is dropping its famous tagline fair
and balanced they're dropped they're
getting rid of it
true story yeah Fox News is swapping it
for the more accurate tagline paranoia
and ads for cialis
it's kind of a cool story there's a new
version of the Bible that has updated
language it's coming out yeah for
example at first to Jesus's disciples as
wingmen that's in the book of bro Cephas
yeah I just don't go out and get hot
wings together astronomers is crazy
astronomers are now speculating that our
Sun may have had a long-lost twin yeah
so it's official or entire solar system
is a telenovela that's nope you gave
that just what it's deserved you have
excellent taste I want to say I'm the
sommelier of comedy and you just perfect
yes an 18-year old field goal kicker
could be the first woman to play in the
NFL
yeah very good yes scouts say she has
the talent and desire all she needs now
is the criminal record suddenly you have
opinions about things I don't know about
that one okay it's fine
new research suggests that people are
more likely to eat vegetables if they
have a tempting name yeah I think
they're right because today for lunch I
had a MILF porn kale salad
you
you